cat fashion photons and load balancers
how do they all relate stay tuned to
learn more for many people one of the
greatest mysteries in the universe is
how in the world Google can return
billions of cat image results in under
one second so I brought my friend URI
here to help explain just how we do that
while the Internet has a whole set of
optimizations to make things like these
searches first Google's global
architecture has its own secret sauce
that allows it to achieve the speed and
accuracy that you've come to know which
prompts many customers and companies to
ask how to leverage that performance for
they own needs
well Google spent the last two decades
building one of the largest fastest
fiber-optic networks in the world to
support Google cloud and Google's own
services you know like YouTube and Gmail
and that network has grown 15 times in
the past six years passing 600 trillion
bits per second across land and through
sea allowing us to service over 1
billion users a day in building this
network Google has had to put in years
of research some of which has made it
back into the community as white papers
which talk about more of the amazing
achievements in technology but we're
getting ahead of ourselves to understand
how big this technology is let's start
by getting small and looking at how the
internet works from the perspective of a
single photon running through Google's
network let's say we just created our
latest web ecommerce site on Google
cloud that serves the latest cat fashion
trends we have some users in Singapore
who are testing our new site and send a
request from their device to purchase
cat winter apparel the request from the
users device will heat the service
provide at first which will realize the
destination is a Google server it will
send it right to the closest Google's
front end server that it can find this G
of es sit at the very edge of Google's
global network with multiple points of
presence why to allow information to be
served as close to the users as possible
like Rio de Janeiro Zurich and Singapore
at this point Google's technological
magic takes over the first thing that
request does is slam into Google Cloud
Software Defined global load balancer
those load balancers responsible for
distributing HTTP and HTTPS traffic
to back ins in order to manage and
distribute load in a scalable way in the
best scenario we've deployed our
software on two VMs running in the
Singapore datacenter in which case the
request is handled and the data is sent
back to the user but let's say the
clause is back-end instance group in
Singapore is unavailable or maybe we
haven't deployed VMs to this region yet
the users request is seamlessly directed
to other Williams we are running
stationed in the u.s. East region what
is great about the global l7 load
balancer is that the routing to a
different region across the globe
happens without the developer having to
lift a finger and configuration is just
a few clicks in the UI it gives you a
single Anika's IP that you can point
traffic to even if the backends go down
what lets the l7 load balancer do this
is the fact that all of the load
balancing is done in software rather
than in hardware it performs a weighted
selection from the set of backends
skipping any backends that appear
unhealthy or whose connections are
saturated this is called the waterfall
by region algorithm and we'll have an
in-depth episode on this on our other
series get cooking in cloud traffic is
proxy through these GF ease which
forwards the query to the selected
back-end running our cat web server now
in our scenario of a user in Singapore
requesting data from a VM in u.s. East
the GF ES and the request across a sub C
fiber optical cable from a pack to the
US which connects various operational
regions of Google cloud these fiber
networks connect cloud regions across
land over thousands of kilometres if
probably passed them and never even
noticed they are underground along
railroad tracks across land on pulse or
even cross mountain ranges and if you're
wondering about the speed photons travel
at tousle of the speed and light in
fiber and with that speed our photons
can carry over two million photos and
eight thousand YouTube videos every
second across our network bear with me
on what happens next that anycast IP the
l7 load balancer has comes with an
Associated forwarding rule which will
then direct traffic to a target proxy
here the target proxy terminates the
client session it has configurations for
a URL map like host and path rules which
then routes the traffic to the correct
back-end service on VMs in the u.s. East
region
the backend service checks each back ins
capacity and house and sends traffic to
the most available and healthy back end
it dance off the shopping data back the
GFE caches the response and forwards it
to the user
and this my friends is how you can
optimize for latency by choosing from
Google clouds globally extensive regions
that are closest to your users even went
back ins are overloaded or unhealthy or
you can use Google clouds content
delivery network to leverage our load
balancing and cache content and closer
to your users but let's go back for a
second we would be remiss if we didn't
discuss in a bit more detail what
happens at the content is sent back to
the user from the backends that the
response has served back to the GFE from
the VM photons are sent from our servers
which are connected to optical
transmission equipment this use infrared
lasers to transmit signals through the
fiber network a typical cable would have
hundreds of optical fibers each made of
a glass with a diameter of just a human
hair and they can transmit signals with
terabits capacity then the photons leave
the Google Data Center through fibers
data bundled in an outside plant cable
but we inevitably face a problem as
photons traveled down fiber-optic cables
their intensity diminishes called
attenuation for example in one of
Google's research papers they
demonstrated what happens when optical
signals travel through 3200 kilometers
looking at the graph you can see that
the relative power level of the signal
decreased so how do photons make it all
the way between regions which are
thousands of kilometers apart the combat
attenuation we place optical amplifiers
along our cables with hundreds of them
on the route amplifiers increase the
signal over long distances so our photon
can make it to the destination the
journey of the photon finally ends back
in Singapore it traveled along fiber
laid underground and strung through the
air getting amplified along the way all
of which happen in just milliseconds our
fiber networks now connect Google Cloud
regions across five continents over the
past ten years through a combination of
buying and leasing google has fiber all
around the world but this is only the
beginning
there's so much more in development to
support our future cloud regions in fact
you
can automatically take advantage of this
by using the premium tier network to
access Google's own global private
network avoiding sub-optimal internet
path check out the link below to learn
more
liked this video if you want more
content like this and remember
optimizing your network means freeing up
your bandwidth
[Music]